hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a pan-cancer view of gene
expression and immunology with
particular applications in ovarian
cancer presented by Wendell Jones he is
currently a principal bioinformatics and
scientific adviser at Q to solutions
EA genomics I am Marjory tourist of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
the for you of trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and les offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Renault Jones I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You Marge
yesterday I would like to talk to you
about a pan-cancer view of immuno
oncology with particular applications in
ovarian cancer and featuring a
particular view using gene expression so
a quick overview I'm going to go a
little bit into the different components
of the immune system and talk about
specific immune cells just so we have a
baseline understanding I'll talk also
about immune response in cancer and
how that plays a role often in many
immunotherapies associated with cancer
I'll also talk about biomarkers of
immune response because one of the
immune therapies that exists currently
are only effective if there is already
an immune response to the tumor that the
cancer patient has and so are most
effective when that immune response is
present
therefore there are biomarkers that are
needed to ensure that we give the right
therapy to the right patients related to
that
I'll also define the immuno which is
essentially the collections of genes
that express in immune cells and
specifically in immune cells and we will
discuss how that has applications for
both biomarker development as well as
understanding both predictive aspects of
response to therapy and prognostic
aspects regarding outcomes of for
patients who are taking immunotherapy
related medications going further I'll
also talk about gene expression that's
specific to immune cells and how these
are often useful biomarkers both for
prediction of responses as well as a
prognostic for outcomes and then I'll
talk about how some of those are being
embodied within immuno oncology panels
and that are available today but also
talk about the ambiguity that exists and
how there is and once that's relatively
little consistency among these these
panels and also our definitions the
immune ohm later though I'll provide a
motivation for understanding some of
these aspects by examining a pan-cancer
view using the Cancer Genome Atlas a
study that's been conducted in this
decade to better define and understand
the the nature of cancer and how it how
it progresses what are the important
biological components and how other
systems such as the immuno interact with
it then I'll cross that the definitions
that I've that I have for the immuno
with the Cancer Genome Atlas to see if
we can learn something about the immuno
them from a pan-cancer view and then
I'll apply these
particular learnings that we would have
from that that crossing of the immune um
with the Cancer Genome Atlas to apply to
biomarkers and potentially also to
understanding survival and ovarian
cancer so let's go to the the first
slide just give you a background of
immune cells so our knowledge of the
immune system has greatly improved over
the last several years certainly many
immune cells are well-known before the
last decade yet there's been a lot of
detail added especially immuno oncology
so as you go down the graph there are
going to be different things that are
more recently understood such as the the
role of for example tissue associated
macrophages that you see here which
we're not necessarily well understood
until a few years ago also there's other
basic things such as understanding of
the adaptive immune aspect of natural
killer cells so until recently natural
killer cells were thought to be strictly
associated with innate immunity now it's
understood they also have an adaptive
immune component and then we'll also
talk about other aspects of the adaptive
immune system such as cd8 positive T
cells as well as other helper cells for
cd8 cells that are associated with cd4
cells and then finally we'll talk about
to give a little bit of look ahead to
what we'll discuss at the end I'll talk
about the importance of natural killer
cells and cd8 t-cells in association
with into Tamm cells and how they can
often be prognostic for outcomes
especially in ovarian cancer but also in
other cancers as well okay so to give an
overview of how biomarkers are often
being used and mean along ecology today
let's first go back to understanding the
systems that are at play so as we know
cancer is a genetic disease a lot of
times cancer arises for example from
changes that occur during cell division
where if someone has impaired mismatch
repair function that often will then
yield how commute ability in subsequent
cells and this is due to the fact that
the polymerase will often create
slippage is when it's trying to do to
fill in the parts of the DNA that are
needed to be filled in when when cells
divide and then when certain celebrities
occur and they are not repaired by the
mismatch repair function then you often
see frame shifts that occur in the in
the DNA encoding regions that can also
be picked up in other regions namely
microsatellites and so microsatellite
instability is a relatively easy way to
pick up on this impaired mismatch repair
function but that's just a biomarker
that's not necessarily the the causation
that's associated with the disease the
causation is more related to things such
as the hyper mutability part which will
eventually potentially present itself as
a higher mutational load or higher
mutational burden that exists in these
cancer cells however there are other
mechanisms that can also lead to higher
mutation of burden besides mismatch
repair defects nevertheless whether it's
mismatch repair defects or other
biological mechanisms the theory is that
the the high current mutability of these
cells leads to higher mutational burden
in the coding regions of genes therefore
creating an increased potential for neo
antigens at the cell surface of
molecules and these neo antigens then
potentially are picked up by the
adaptive immune system and potentially
provoke an immune response or
immunogenicity in the in the tumor
microenvironment however there are also
other biological mechanisms that
potentially can provoke an immune
response as well nevertheless whether
it's microlight instability or tumor
mutational burden or neo antigen type
testing that's often done with protein
type of assays or whether it's look
specific immune cells such as cd8
positive T cells or cd4 positive T cells
or natural killer cells these are often
potential biomarkers for understanding
whether or not there is either immune
response related to a cancer or a
potential for immune response in
oncology one thing it's important to
understand is that even if there is an
immune response that that is not the
final word so there's often a yin and
yang of immune regulation related to
cancer cells and how they interact with
the immune ohm so for example you have
immunogenicity where you have the
adaptive immune system primarily
attempting to to detect and eradicate
cancer cells but sometimes it also can
kill healthy cells at the same time and
in fact of course autoimmune disorders
are related to the immune system killing
healthy cells so so that certainly there
is in the tumor microenvironment there
are certain things that are promoting
the the killing of cancer cells which
whether it's like cd8 positive T cells
which kill cancer cells directly or
whether it's other factors such as
interferon gamma or cd4 helper cells
that are essentially activating or
promoting the activity of cd8 T cells so
those are being stimulated and hopefully
in the tumor microenvironment they are
finding attacking and killing tumor
cells but there's also a yang part where
in order to prevent the killing of
healthy cells and sometimes in in this
case it may also prevent the killing of
cancer cells there are other important
regulatory mechanisms such as regulatory
t regulatory cells also checkpoint
blockades that occur more or less at the
point of attack of cd8 positive T cells
with cancer cells and there's other
regulatory mechanisms such as those
implemented by the tumor associated m2
macrophage cell type so these may be
either blocking or suppressing the
activity of immune cells and therefore
even though you
an immune response that as your body has
discovered the cancer cells that you
know that seem to be alien the immune
system is having a hard time finding and
killing the cancer cells because there
are these other mechanisms there in
place to prevent the killing of healthy
cells so let's go into a little bit more
definition of the immuno and the amino
has been described in a couple of
different important papers one that I
like a great deal was published by
Newman and Nature Methods in 2016 where
they basically examined 22 different
types of immune cells and they also
identified over 500 genes that expressed
specifically in these immune cells now
these genes may not express just in one
immune cell they may express in a
variety of immune cells but they only
express in these immune cells and not in
other cells such as stromal cells or
tumor cells that that may be in the in
the tumor micro-environment
so in one sense they are important
markers for us to understand the
activity and the presence of immune
cells in that environment and so you see
here's a you know just an excerpt from
that where you have a large list of
genes and then the points in red are
those immune cells that that particular
gene is expressed in and then the blue
areas are indicating that the that
particular gene is not expressing in
that particular immune cell and you see
that there's a wide variety there's some
genes that only express for example in
particular dendritic cells but then
there's a lot of cells that express in a
variety of different T cells or other
adaptive you know immune cell types
there's also another definition if you
like of the immuno that was published by
bindiya in 2013 one different aspect
about the bindiya paper was that it also
described temporal effects that is that
occur in the tumor microenvironment
where you may have certain genes that
are associated with immune cells only
expressing in certain phases of the of
the tumor
the tumors life as it
it progresses from one stage to another
so here you have this idea that yes the
the the immune cells that are in the
tumor microenvironment may be expressing
indicating immune activity but sometimes
these immune cells are typically only
present during certain stages of the
tumor and so that's another important
aspect and potentially understanding not
only is their immune activity present
but maybe what stage the the tumor is in
as well now one complication of the
bindiya defined immune ohm is that
whereas on the Neuman amino that you
just saw sometimes certain genes were
associated with multiple immunity cell
types in this case been the only mapped
a gene to one particular cell class so
this sometimes creates complications for
genes with multiple class associations
and we can see that in the next slide
where when we try to examine an overlap
of the different amino definitions that
is we take Vindhyas list of several
hundred genes and then we take newman's
list of several hundred genes and we
look for overlap that we find there's
actually relatively a small amounts of
overlap between them maybe only 25% or
so and then we have the complication
that bindiya has really a list of genes
and what class of immune cells
associated with or as Newman is very
specific saying this gene is expressed
in one or more cell types of the amino
so here you know we see that not only is
there a little overlap but there may
also be different ways of thinking about
the immune ohm in terms of whether genes
are you know relevant to certain classes
or relevant to to to certain cell types
so with respect to even certain classes
of the immuno for example if we just
look at the genes that for example
bindiya says are associated with cd8
t-cells you know exclusively we see that
again here we see a little overlap
between the bindiya definition of the
cd8 t-cell immuno versus newman's
definition only six genes out of you
know potentially
you know fifty or more so again a little
overlap in the definition which means
that we we are still incomplete and our
knowledge of genes that are associated
with immune cells and and how they
function and how they relate to other
immune cells this is also reflected in
panels that have been derived from
knowledge of both cancer and the immune
ohm so for example companies such as
Nana string and HTG have developed
immuno oncology related panels where
they're trying to measure both the
immuno m-- genes in the immuno basically
a gene expression assay as well as genes
that may be important for you know tumor
related activities such as proliferation
or this regulation of metabolism or
possibly even defeat of the immune
system so here we have panels that maybe
have several hundred genes in them we
have the Newman and bindiya definitions
of the immuno which again are associated
with several hundred genes but in terms
of whether they overlap or not you see
that in one sense there often is very
little overlap between you know these
different either definitions the immuno
or essentially gene lists associated
with the panels that are trying to
measure the immune system in the context
of the tumor micro-environment
so so for example if you look at all
four of these classes of genes there's
only about 46 genes that overlap out of
really over a thousand genes that are
assisted with any one of these
particular panels so one solution to
that is to at this point since many
things seem to be less well defined or
less well understood than maybe we would
like is to have a broad view and use a
technology such as RNA sequencing to get
the the full transcriptome and then once
we learn more about particular aspects
of the immune ohm and the tumor
microenvironment will be able to
properly associate different genes with
different functions in the immuno and
also different aspects of
tomber related activity so to summarize
so far what we have in terms of our
knowledge is that immune cells are
actually very diverse as in immune
oncology as well as and other things
such as infectious disease and the
important thing is we're still learning
about them as I mentioned before natural
killer cells were thought until recently
to be exclusively associated with innate
immunity but now we understand that they
have a large role in adaptive immunity
and they also have a role in amino
oncology as well we understand now that
immune response in cancer is diverse and
has a large number of interdependencies
both in the immuno m-- that is you have
different cells that are helping other
cells such as antigen presenting cells
or follicular helper cells of cd4 T
cells these are all in essence helping
certain cytotoxic cells such as cd8 or
natural killer cells to basically enlist
them activate them and attack the cancer
but there's also opposing forces such as
macrophage into Tam related cells T
regulatory cells and also different
checkpoints such as the well-known pd-1
PDL one checkpoint that are sort of an
opposing force to the immune system
attacking the tumors and serve as sort
of a checks and balances to prevent
other harmful access such as
autoimmunity we also know that the
immuno is not completely well-defined
even though parts of it are well
understood and that's more or less made
evident by the variety of the immune UM
definitions as well as the panels that
have come out recently to measure I mean
system activity as well as the gene
expression in the in the tumors that
they are potentially attacking so so our
partial knowledge of immune cells are
makeup in their behavior in this tumor
microenvironment still means that there
are some gaps that we need to fill in
and so therefore it could be that if
what you're measuring is well understood
then those panels may be well suited for
that purpose otherwise there are still
other mechanisms such as using
transcript on why'd RNA seek to measure
these different aspects so that you can
get a full picture of the tumor
microenvironment but then another
question comes around as to what does
this all mean in other words if we knew
the immune ohm and it's activity
perfectly what would that tell us and so
one answer to that is that several drugs
have been approved recently that
essentially are boosting the immune
system for certain oncology patients
many by interrupting the pd-1 PDL one
checkpoint so for example here are some
examples of immunotherapy drugs that
have been proved and in the most of many
of them in the last few years such as
Nivola map or a paluma map and and you
see that many of them are actually
targeting this PD 1p do one checkpoint
initially approve four treatments in
certain types of cancers but it could be
that actually these drugs may work in a
variety of cancers which is what I'll
talk about a little bit later however
one important aspect of these
immunotherapies is that these therapies
only work if the tumor has already
elicited an immune response in other
words a lot of these particular
therapies are essentially another aid to
an immune adaptive immune system that
may already have recognized the tumor
it's just now that they are removing
some of the blockades or some of the
checkpoints that may prevent the immune
cells from from attacking the the
particular tumor cells that they're in
essence looking for those new antigens
on the surface of those cancer cells
that they're looking for so the question
is how can we tell if there is an immune
response to the tumor so that we know
that if we give a particular patient I
mean oh therapy that will actually have
the intended effect and this their
quantifiable evidence of immunogenicity
in the tumor micro-environment
that that level of immunogenicity is
associated with better outcomes so
whether or not you have an immunotherapy
or not is the fact that your adaptive
immune system has already recognized the
tumor does that end of itself lead to
better outcomes and so understanding
that will guide us a lot regarding both
what kind of therapies and how we end up
ultimately treating the patient so
related to does immunogenicity lead to
better outcomes this has been addressed
at least for certain casters and one
good summary view of this was published
last year in iglasia in je and CI where
they examined eleven different cancer
types from the Cancer Genome Atlas which
is some data that I'll show you in just
a few moments where they were looking at
things like bladder cancer breast cancer
colorectal cancer glioblastoma which was
recently made more well-known by Senator
John McCain's diagnosis of having
glioblastoma kidney cancer lung cancer
so forth including ovarian cancer and so
they were looking at published immune
related signatures and you can see some
of those more or less on the left-hand
side not to worry about the details of
which ones but let's just say that there
are various related gene expression
signatures have been published about the
immuno they include things such as PD 1
and PDO 1 which you've already mentioned
the gene ctla4 which is also another
checkpoint related gene B cells t-cells
and then also macrophage and and
potentially other genes such as
dendritic cells all those make up
different parts of the immuno and they
may have relevance to different aspects
of better outcomes for certain cancer
patients so this is the idea that
iglasia and his colleagues examined
which is let's look at different immune
signatures for gene expression let's
look at different cancers and let's see
if we can determine whether or not
different immune signatures are
prognostic related to these outcomes for
these several different cancers so they
published their results and for example
some of the results they found were that
breast head-and-neck certain lung
cancers melanoma and endometrial cancer
showed improved survival among patients
with tumors that had
a high level of immune activity in their
tumor micro environment essentially
infiltrating leukocytes and lymphocytes
and then separately immune signatures
have appeared related to colorectal
cancer especially colorectal subtypes
and those have also been associated with
survival in that again higher immune
related activity is often associated
with better outcomes however really to
ovarian cancer it's been a different
story at least a mixed story to this
point so for example ovarian cancer was
studied extensively in the Cancer Genome
Atlas and was extended from both a DNA
perspective looking at mutations as well
as looking at RNA gene expression and
surprisingly in the original nature
paper that that was published for
ovarian cancer survival time was not
shown to be significantly associated
with the so-called immunoreactive also
known as immuno genic subtype that was
identified for one particular class of
ovarian tumor patients also in the
connecting paper that followed on to
that they also did not find an
association with survival for the
original signature technique and his
colleagues developed their own signature
that they showed in a different cohort
of patients was associated with survival
but essentially we are getting a mixed
message related to immune activity and
ovarian cancer related to survival
because we have you know one main paper
that did not find the Association
looking at a large number of samples in
this case around almost 500 samples and
then the connecting paper which for a
smaller set of patients actually did
find an association so when I decided to
do was to in essence go back to the
Cancer Genome Atlas and take a de novo
approach looking across many different
types of cancer to see if we can
understand that there are certain
patterns that appear in almost any
cancer and then see if those in
particular patterns also apply to
ovarian cancer so I started with
over 25 cancer types and subtypes that
exist in TCGA looking at the gene
expression and specifically the RNA
sequencing data because that's usually a
very high quality it was all done more
or less by one institution in a very
consistent fashion so as opposed to for
example microarray data which can often
suffer from batch effects and other
institutional effects the RNA seek data
should be very very consistent and so
it's a viewed as a cleaner source from
which to do some initial analysis and so
related to the Cancer Genome Atlas for
those of you familiar with it you also
know that even though there's a wide
variety of cancer types within each
given cancer there also may be a wide
variety of samples in terms of their
number and other and subtypes that may
exist and so for example breast cancer
has over a thousand samples currently in
the Cancer Genome Atlas that has RNA
sequencing data whereas other cancers
may only have you know less than less
than 100 so in order to not have the
information that I'm trying to look at
paint you know paint cancer be swamped
by the over-representation of a
particular cancer in that collection
well I decided to do was randomly sample
up to 200 tumor samples from each type
so that we don't have
over-representation bias and then what I
did was essentially intersect that gene
expression data from those tumor samples
with the genome definition from Numan to
examine patterns of immune cell activity
in these in this large number of cancers
and of course even with only selecting
up to 200 tumor samples from each type
since I'm looking at over 25 types
you're going to be examining several
thousand cancer specimens tumor
specimens and you know from the Cancer
Genome Atlas so here we're going to look
at expressions and patterns of
expression in several thousand tumor
samples to see if we can learn things
from that that may be both specific to
certain cancer types but which also may
be applicable across me
different cancer types so to do that we
normalize the RNA seek data so that we
can compare sample to sample and then we
examine clustered expression patterns
across again almost 4,500 different
tumor samples so what we're looking for
is in the immune own definition of Numan
which has about 500 genes working for a
strong co-expression that may be
evidence of potential Co regulation or
at least coordinated biological systems
so here is a clustered heat map that
results from looking at that neumann
immune um definition as you see I've
color-coded different aspects of the
immune UM related to different types of
cells so for example b-cells are coded
gray T cells have a red and green
association not your killer cells are
coded in blue then you have macrophage
and other parts of the innate immune
system coded in purple and so in this
case each gene is represented by a row
in this particular sample matrix so so
the genes are are here each row and you
can see that the color is coordinating
to the different immune immune um
definitions and then each column is a
different tumor type and so here what
I've done is I've clustered the
expression of these different tumors so
that they will be clustered both by
their the sample level and also at the
gene level so they can look for
coordinated aspects of gene expression
and when you look at that with the
entire immune ohm what you see is that
in fact there's clustering of two
different types they're still clustering
by cancer types so for example here are
different types of neural cancers that
exist in brain glioblastoma low-grade
glioma here's prostate cancer which has
a big cluster here's liver cancer which
has a big cluster and so forth and so on
but you also see that there's a
particular group of genes in the middle
here that are clustering together that
are not directly associated with
specific cancers in fact the the area
here becomes much
more blurred in terms of which cancers
that it's associated with and so what we
see is that these tea and natural killer
cell genes genes associated with only
tea and nitric kill shells as well as
some b-cells and so forth are
potentially associated with many
different types of cancer and in fact
this is the adaptive immune system this
is evidence of the adaptive immune
system recognizing and attempting to to
kill tumor cells because it views them
as being alien in the in the body so
we're going to focus on a particular
group of these T and natural killer or
cell gene expression patterns in
particular we're going to look at a
particular subtype of tightly correlated
genes associated with T and natural
killer cells and we're going to
essentially pull those out and then
requestor the entire set of 4,500 tumor
samples and when we do that we see the
the following graph and what we notice
here is is actually rather striking
first we see more clearly the
composition of the t and natural killer
cell aspects within this particular
cluster we see them in the red and light
blue and we also see them also
essentially separating almost all the
tumor samples into what I will call very
hot tumors that is tumors that have
strong evidence of immune response and
immune activity in the in the tumor
microenvironment and then we also see
some cold tumors that is tumors that
really don't show probably any evidence
of adaptive immune activity because
again the B cells natural killer cells T
cells are more associated with adaptive
immunity rather than innate immunity and
we also see that for example vo blastoma
low-grade glioma still cluster but they
tend to be cold tumors that as we tend
to see these tumors as not having much
activity related to the adaptive immune
system doesn't mean that the innate
immune system can't be involved in in
those particular cancers but at least
related to the adaptive means
system it's very rare for the adaptive
immune system to identify these brain
associated cancers okay so this is
interesting we definitely see strong
evidence of certain tumors having an
adaptive immune response and other
tumors not having an adaptive immune
response and that the adaptive immune
response does not seem to be as
particular related to whatever cancer
type it may have identified as having
these new antigens that are there alien
and thus it's trying to potentially
attack them and kill them to to
essentially ward off in an invasion just
like it would an infection so so the
question is okay it's interesting that
we have these hot and cold tumors the
question is are they is this information
going to be prognostic so so we're going
to talk about that in just a second
specifically related to ovarian cancer
first I just wanted to summarize in
essence some of the cancers where in
essence there seems to be a fair amount
of immune activity and where there is
not as much immune activity and what you
can see here from this particular graph
is that by the the shaded bar charts
that you that you see below different
cancers had different levels of adaptive
immune system activity so for example we
see in one particular type of lung
cancer there's often a high probability
of immune activity whereas as we
mentioned before in glow grade glioma or
glioblastoma here is low-grade glioma
but we see that hardly any of the
cancers in TCGA have evidence of
adaptive immune behavior so this leads
us to different cancers that are more
likely to be hot that is have evidence
of the adaptive immune system versus
other cancers that are more likely not
and so you see that there are there are
certain cancers such as long miss
ophelia ma testicular cancer stomach
cancer and some others that have a high
probability of the immune system
recognising those cancers then there are
other cancers such as glioblastoma and
low-grade glioma which you mentioned
before but also things such as pairing
ganglioma which is another nerve related
cancer as well as I believe kidney
chromophobe have very little likelihood
of at least otherwise you know
unstimulated having a adaptive immune
activity in the tumor microenvironment
so now we get to ovarian cancer and we
see that ovarian cancer is somewhere in
between so there are certain tumors that
seem to have immune activity and others
don't
one question is is this potentially
related outcomes and again at the end
I'll talk about whether or not these
particular patients potentially have
higher likelihood than not of better
outcomes but first also want to
associate the graph that you just saw
with another idea that we had mentioned
early on that is often used for
biomarkers related to immune response
and that's tumor mutational burden so
there have been a few famous papers that
have published information about tumor
mutational burden and their prevalence
across many different cancer types and
so this is one particular more famous
paper by Lawrence that said that
essentially mutational burden can vary
by cancer type with for example melanoma
and different lung cancers having higher
mutation or burden and then going all
the way down to the bottom cancers such
as kidney chromophobe and different
types of leukemia as well as potentially
other brain diseases like Leo blastoma
have lower evidence of tumor mutational
burden and that two limitation of burden
was often associated you know if you
follow the model that I had before with
thus increased likelihood of the Atlanta
jhin's and increased likelihood no
antigens potentially also implies a
greater immune response or greater
potential for immune response so the
question is when we look at this
particular graph of tumor mutation a
burden associated with different cancer
types and the graph that I showed
previously which is what I would call
more direct evidence of adaptive immune
presents and the tumors do they line up
so what we can do is we can look at them
you know again in the large so on the
left-hand side I have the order in the
lawrence paper as you see with melanoma
and long and bladder cancer up top again
not surprised that that that these
particular tissues may have more
evidence of mutational burden because
those are the ones that are more exposed
to the elements such as you know
radiation or ingest you know to
particulates in the air those can often
lead to damage the damage can result in
DNA defects as cells divide so it's no
surprise that that that skin and lung
and whatever would potentially have
higher mutational burden related to the
different cancers but when we look at
the ordered immuno genic tumor
percentage from TCA that i just showed
you you see that there's not necessarily
a hundred percent agreement that is even
though the tumor mutational burden may
potentially lead to neo antigens and
immune response when we actually look at
tumors that have immune response it's
not a perfect correlation and in fact
what we see is that even though melanoma
is more likely to have a high tumor
mutational burden when we actually look
at melanoma tumors they are more or less
in the middle in terms of their immune
response so they're much less likely
than other tumors to have an immune
response and then there are other
cancers such as pancreatic cancer that
tend to have very low mutational burden
yet when we look at the percentage of
those cancers in TCGA that have strong
evidence of immune response we see that
it's much much higher okay and it tends
to be more at the top of the list so
what that implies is that even though
tumor mutational burden may be an
important biomarker it's certainly not
the last word related to immunogenicity
and in fact here we have you know strong
evidence using RNA of immunogenicity and
and we see that some cancers are not
associated with the level of temptation
a burden that that one might think
okay so getting back to our plan we
wanted to take the genes that we showed
before that were where we were examining
things paying cancer and look at in
particular at a high-grade serous
ovarian cancer subset of RNA seek data
from TCGA and so with that view when we
take those genes from that particular
section of the immuno associated with
gene expression in in T cells and
natural killer cells we see that that
these tumors which are in columns do
seem to break down into tumors that show
large evidence of having immune response
and then also tumors that have less
evidence I'm even being very cold which
is in this big green area here in the
middle and then there are some you know
tumors that are more less in between you
know they're there they're not quite
cold they're not quite hot so in essence
there's a continuum if you like of
immune response related to different
tumors you know from ovarian cancer and
even you know in in TCGA so the question
is again do patients who have immune
response and ovarian tumors do they show
high likelihood of better outcomes the
the literature to this point has been
mixed results in that the original
nature paper and ovarian cancer in TCGA
as well as ecclesia did not find an
association connecting took a different
cohort and said there was a connection
the question is you know what's what's
the the truth here so why I decided to
do was to not only look at T and natural
killer cell expression but also look at
other things such as b-cell in one
macrophage as well as the into Tam
macrophage which potentially is a yang
to the yin of T and natural killer cells
as well as b-cells
to see if there may be some interaction
going on between these two different
systems and so I'm taking signatures for
these different types of immune related
cells and I'm going to
turn them into continuous scores to
indicate a level of activity of those
particular signatures in this particular
type of cancer and I'm going to do
proportional hazard regression using Cox
regression and show whether or not these
signatures are significant therefore
prognostic in ovarian cancer for for the
TCGA ovarian cancer as well as some of
connect these data and then just to make
things a little bit simpler because
we're using continuous rules for Cox
regression I'm going to convert some of
these signatures to a binary call off
basically making the choice as to
whether or not we say there's immune
activity or not or there's m2 tab
presence or not and make illustrative
kaplan-meier curves which are often you
know shown in publications illustrating
the differences in survival between
different classes of patients so here
we're going to examine both event-free
and overall survival using that method
and we're going to examine key immune
ohm components as well as some usual
clinical factors such as age and stage
because agent stage are often used as
sort of a baseline to understand whether
or not there are differences in survival
you know again relate the patient's age
or related to the stage of the cancer
often the higher the age or the later of
the stage it typically implies worse
outcomes for many cancers and then we'll
look at hazard ratios but because
hundred ratios are a little bit complex
to interpret with expression signatures
especially you know since these are
scores that are not as well defined for
say you know across you know many
different environments they're more less
dependent upon the scale and
distribution of scores for this
presentation I'll just primarily examine
the direction of the hazard ratio to
make sure that for example doesn't match
our intuition that is if we see more tea
and natural killer cell gene expression
which implies the presence of the cd8 T
cells as well as natural killer cells we
see more of that present does that tend
to lower the hazard or lead to better
outcomes for for these ovarian cancer
patients and then one other important
thing which I think is
related to my work with collaborators in
ovarian cancer we want to not
necessarily look at all ovarian cancer
patients we want to look at a cohort of
uniformly treated ovarian cancer
patients which I don't necessarily think
was done you know prior to this where we
say okay let's look at patients who have
a minimum of six courses of adjuvant
platinum-based chemotherapy and look at
the implication of these offerings I'm
sorry these immune related signatures in
these are very impatient hsihu are
uniformly treated so when we look at
that from a Cox regression viewpoint
here are some results where I'm showing
two models that one uses the essentially
more innate immune signature but which
may be recruiting adaptive immune
helpers which is the m1 macrophage and
we see that the m1 macrophage is
significant across these three different
data sets that is looking at TCGA
event-free survival looking at TCGA
overall survival as well as the
connected data set overall survival in
fact not only is it significant it's
highly significant and as significant in
the ways that you would think are
reasonable that is the in one signature
them basically the greater the presence
the lower the hazard but when you have
the yang part which is the m2 Tamm
signature there are the greater the
present the the higher the hazard and
this is again matches our intuition
because we typically associate the m2
tumor associated macrophage with being
more tumor promoting and down railing of
the immune immune system in the tumor
microenvironment so it's not only
prognostic but also matches our
intuition about that and what's also to
me somewhat surprising is that they are
highly significant whereas age and stage
are not significant or not as
significant and then we go to for
example the the the more cd8 oriented T
and and also the natural killer cell
signature and we see that it often is as
significant or sometimes even more
significant depending upon the data set
then the the m1 signature but we also
see that the m2 Tam correspondingly also
is highly significant and
so and it's again it's significant in
the ways that you would think that is
the more of the cytotoxic t and natural
killer cells that exist the lower the
hazard for the patient both from an
event free and overall survival
viewpoint but when we get to the M to
Tam that the higher of that presence the
worse the outcome so again this is
reflective of the yin and yang that I
was mentioning earlier that is often
going on but it also shows that that
even for the TCGA ovarian cancer
datasets when you look at patients that
are uniformly treated that the immune
system is very much prognostic when it
comes to outcomes and moreover one
interesting thing that isn't shown here
so if we only look at higher levels of M
to town by itself in the model that is
we take out either the m1 signature or
the cd8 natural killer cell signature it
is not significant by itself which means
that it really is something that is
associated directly with the potentially
the adaptive or other parts of the
immune system in that higher levels of
into tamar only important if you also
have a muted apt of immune cell presence
okay so it's not important by itself
it's only important in helping to
clarify or contextualize the the
adaptive immune response for example
from the cytotoxic lymphocytes okay so
again just to give a different
perspective of at least the here I'm
illustrating the the cd8 natural killer
immuno genic adaptive response for the
event free survival we see that the the
patients who do have an adaptive immune
response again that are uniformly
treated have an obvious enhanced
survival probability in fact you see
evidence a potentially durable response
in the immuno genic part whereas the
patients who have less or no immune
response have worse outcomes related to
event free survival and this is also
carried over in overall survival so
again whether it's event free or overall
survival in TCGA we see evidence
of the importance of understanding the
immune system and and it's potentially
leading to to better outcomes even in
ovarian cancer which isn't well
understood or wasn't well known you know
up to this point so just to summarize
this part the adaptive immune component
is observed and expressed in most tissue
types there are exceptions such as glial
cells and other related cells where you
don't see the adaptive immune component
as much we also see that some tumor
tissues tend to have higher levels of
infiltrating lymphocytes at least you
know is represented by TCGA in this case
we also seen both from uglisha and from
for other cancer types specifically for
this research that in ovarian cancer the
presence of these infiltrating
lymphocytes is frequently associated
with better outcomes and so so we've
tried to take this pain cancer
expression signature apply it to two
high-grade serous ovarian cancer
patients and the hope is potentially
that this same signature will be useful
in other cancers so that we can more or
less have a a standard more standard
view a more common view of both the
immune response and and whether or not
it plays a role in outcomes associated
with different cancers but interestingly
enough in ovarian cancer we do see
strong evidence that the impute am
signature is negatively associated with
outcome especially in the presence of a
tumor immune response so just to have a
final summary as I mentioned before
cancer and the immuno or each of them by
themselves complex systems and then you
put them together they have complex
interactions even within the immune um
the components of the immuno them and
their function is the object of current
research it's not completely to known or
well-defined yet especially in oncology
and then for discovery purposes as a
result it may be best to consider more
transcriptome wine methods until you
have a validated signature in which case
you can go to more focused panels and
those should be you know well suited for
that purpose
and while there are biomarkers such as
my croissant light instability into
mutational burden for potential immune
response we also see here from TCGA that
tumor mutational burden is not perfectly
associated with direct measurement of
the immune response using gene
expression in the tumor microenvironment
and i think that's an important aspect
because why rst mb is an important
measure if you're actually trying to
measure immune response there's nothing
better than trying to look at gene
expression of the tumor correctly
and you'll probably get a better answer
we've also seen that paying cancer views
on the immuno can be instructive in
terms of giving robust signatures and
that these immune signatures can often
be prognostic for outcomes and many
cancers including ovarian cancer and
with that I'll conclude and I want to
acknowledge some people such as the
Cancer Genome Atlas consortium as well
as some colleagues such as Joel Parker
the Lineberger Cancer Institute at UNC
Chapel Hill as well as dr. ramen root
Ganapathy at Levine Cancer Center and
carolinas HealthCare in Charlotte North
Carolina so with that I'll turn it back
over to Marg thank you dr. Jones for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button for answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is what are
potential reasons for the lack of close
agreement between tumor mutational
burden and adaptive immune activity in
the tumor micro-environment okay that's
a good question
there are you know many potential
reasons so for example tumor mutational
burden essentially assumes that one
particular mutation has the same
potential as another and I think we know
that there are certainly going to be
some mutations that have bigger impacts
on the potentially resulting protein
that may make it more easily recognized
by the immune system also there's all
the the patient's own genetic makeup for
example like in hla regions as well as
their adaptive immune capability so for
example we know that for some patients
their adaptive immune system may not be
as efficient as they get older versus
when they're they're younger so there
are you know potentially many reasons
why there there isn't a close agreement
related to specific tissues that is a
little bit of surprise because you know
the genetic component should be the same
across you know another the genetic
component for a person should be the
same across tissues but obviously there
are there are different aspects of the
tissue itself that may allow for greater
access to the immune system so that you
know I think it's important to consider
that there are both aspects there's
there's a potential part there's also if
you can measure directly maybe the
actual the actual results that you can
you can measure for example using gene
expression from the tumor
microenvironment because we do know of
these these cells having very specific
genes that are associated with with them
so I mean there's many reasons I don't
think all of it is is well understood at
this point thank you for that answer our
next question is what is the better
biomarker or in manage in the city tumor
mutational burden or a protein or
expression based marker or signature
from immune cells in the tumor
microenvironment yeah so this is also a
complex question what's a better model
marker for immunogenicity in one sense
some of the the best biomarkers could
potentially be protein based biomarkers
and in fact protein based biomarkers are
often used in immunohistochemistry by
pathologists to determine whether or not
there are specific types of immune cells
there are complications there you know
there's an assumption that the
antibodies are going to be properly
made insensitive for the type of marker
that the ones looking for also there's a
limitation often in terms of how many
different types of proteins or genes
that can be interrogated at the same
time and as we saw the amino is often
complex and and you may need to
potentially interrogate several genes in
order to understand the immune response
or the state of the immune response in
that particular tumor so there's going
to be some where I think that if you're
trying to measure immunogenicity
directly I would say you would need to
use some type of protein or expression
based marker or signature of the tumor
itself the the protein part can also
potentially give advantages related to
spatial interpretations the expression
based gives advantages in terms of the
thoroughness or completeness in which
you can you know examine obviously many
thousands of analytes simultaneously if
it's an expression based biomarker and
then tmb I think is useful for some
context related to potential
immunogenicity but it is not a direct
measure of immunogenicity so I would
tend to think that if you're trying to
measure immunogenicity versus potential
that you know a protein or expression
based biomarker it would probably be
better for the cells in the tumor
microenvironment thank you our last
question is are other immune cell
signatures associated with outcomes or
response yeah so here I did highlight
for example the more the for example the
cytotoxic lymphocytes such as t-cells
cd8 t-cells and the natural killer cells
which are very important I also
mentioned you know m1 and m2 Tamm
macrophage but it turns out that for
example b-cells can also be an effective
signature and in fact if I were to
replace the the cd8 and natural killer
cell signature with a b-cell signature
it would also be significant in the
context of ovarian cancer
as well as a few other immune related
signatures this is not a surprise
especially b-cell and and the cytotoxic
t-cells because they're often working
together you know b-cells presenting
antigens for these particular cd8
t-cells and natural killer cells they're
also working to create antibodies so if
you have a lot of b-cells in the the
microenvironment that may be one of the
the leaders in terms of trying to
activate cd8 t-cells or recruit other
related cells so that they can in
essence you know bring the adaptive
immune system to bear on the tumor so
yes other immune cell signatures can be
associated with outcomes and potentially
also response to treatments and I didn't
mean that
for it for the ones I presented here to
be the the only ones exclusive of any
other you know type of immune signature
I would like to once again thank dr.
Wendell Jones for his presentation I
would also like to thank laberd's for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2017 you'll receive
an email from laggards letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay they should have announcements
with your colleagues who might have
missed today's libel bit that's all for
now thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again soon goodbye